If you like bikes, then you should come to Copenhagen, Denmark...
...because there are lots of them.
Bikes, bikes, bikes, bikes, bikes, everywhere.
Since I love bikes, I'm in a very good city to be.
And if you happen to arrive in Denmark without your trusty bicycle, have no fear.
You can rent one for free.
All you need is...
...20 crowns right here.
It's this easy, stick it right in the little thing.
Push it in, oh!
You got yourself a happy face bicycle.
There is no better way to see Copenhagen than by bike.
Let's cruise!
They take their biking so seriously in Copenhagen...
...that the bikes have their own lane right next to the cars...
...and right next to the sidewalk where everybody walks.
If you step foot into the bike lane, get ready to get run over.
And the great thing is people of all ages ride bikes.
Moms, dads, old guys, young guys, and even the postman or woman.
And to go along with the special bike lanes,...
...there are also special bike traffic lights.
Green means go!
Bicycles are used for just about everything in Denmark...
...like carrying kids and taking out the trash and newspapers and taxis.
And whoa! What was that crazy Jetson-looking thing?
So after you've ridden circles around this beautiful city of Copenhagen,...
...you bring your bike back to one of these special bike racks,...
...get your money back and you're ready to roll.
Stick this thing in there, money pops out,...
...you get a nice and shiny 20 crowns.
You know what this is good for?
A beer.
Let's go get a beer.
Cheers!
Thanks for riding with me.